the parents are black teenage boy killed
in the police involved shooting in Texas
won't the officer to be held accountable
form a ball Springs police officer Roy
Oliver who is white is charged with
murder he's accused of shooting and
killing 15 year old jordan Edwards in
April as the teenager left a party the
Justice Department has also launched an
investigation the Edwards family spoke
to our Omar Villafranca in their first
television interview
Omar's outside the vault Springs Police
Department oh my good morning good
morning Charmaine and oh dela Edwards
say their son Jordan was an honor
student he loved football and had a
bright future it has been almost three
weeks since the incident but Charmaine
has not gone back to church because that
would require her to drive by the spot
where her son was killed go in his room
and I'm waiting on him to walk through
the door like to have my last for him to
say bye I'm gone it's like never happy
for Charmaine and Odell Edwards the
death of their 15 year old son Jordan
does not seem real I'll have his pitches
now throughout the house and on my phone
you saved the pictures on your phone yes
yes every day I think up the pitches
Zeca see according to the arrest warrant
for Balch Springs police officer Roy
Oliver on April 29th he shot and killed
the teenager outside a house party
jordan his two brothers and two friends
were driving away in a car
Oliver allegedly fired multiple shots
into the sedan after unsuccessfully
trying to get them to stop a bullet
struck Jordan in the head as he sat in
the front passenger seat next to his 16
year old stepbrother Vidal you're in the
car have you replayed that moment in
your head every night
can't even sleep what do you do to to
kind of just breathe
I pray what do you pray for peace in my
heart and get rid of my anger their
oldest brother Stephen was in the
backseat when he saw Jordan slumped over
you're 17 what goes through your mind
when you see your brother I was angry
and expect for it to be him I do you
have questions
Balch Springs Police Chief Jonathan
Hebert said body camera footage of the
incident revealed police behavior that
didn't measure up to the department's
core values Oliver was fired on May 2nd
and three days later after an
investigation by the Dallas County
Sheriff's Office he was charged with
murder
if the car was leaving the scene and
wasn't posing a threat so anyone why
shoot but you literally shooting like
you planned
target practice that's how this in my
mind that's what is like he was hunting
you use rifles to kill animals that's
what you do
and that's what he needs following
Jordans shooting the boys pulled over
for help and were confronted by officers
who detained them before being
handcuffed Vidal says an officer called
him the N word and he worried he'd be
shocked I thought that that was Brant to
my head like I didn't I'm not gonna be
able to say goodbye to my parents what
my brother did I have did you have the
same thoughts as veedol yes in a
statement the Balch Springs Police
Department told CBS News they've
reviewed many hours from officers body
cameras and in-car cameras and have not
heard any of the officers used the N
word to describe the boys the Edwards
say they want meaningful change which
for them means seeing Oliver locked up
what would you tell Roy Oliver about
Jordan you killed a anything kid life
that were majoring in smile if you know
the family says they don't believe all
cops are bad but they say that cops who
break the law need to be held
accountable as for Oliver he posted his
bail and was released but he has not
spoken publicly Norah
all right Omar thinks this is such a
disturbing family it's disturbing story
and I feel for that family I do too
I mean listen nobody believes that all
police officers are bad but it's very
difficult when you look at that video
I'm it's another example of why it's
good to have the video to get the whole
story and put it in context but it's
heartbreaking here I didn't realize that
his brothers were in the car either
which makes it all so very painful
traumatic for them